an Oscar nominee in 1997 for his
performance in Pulp Fiction samuel
l.jackson
you've just seen powerful evidence of
how a documentary can chronicle
illuminate or move of people to action
one of the following documentary
features has been selected to join their
company children underground he deep
felsberg lolis ken the legacy of cotton
susan flunky and deprecates
murder on a Sunday morning John's a VA
della Strada and Denis on sale promises
Justine Shapiro and BC Goldman
war photographer Christian fraud
and the Oscar goes to murder on a Sunday
morning James IV a genocide and can he
fall say
film is about respect under booty
see shove them we just saw on the clip
one of the greatest men in America and
he said in 1963 the year I was born I
have a dream that my four children will
one day live in a in one nation where
they will not be judged by the color of
their skin but by the content of their
character 38 years later where film with
Danny passe a story about teenager
we have been stopped arrested and sent
to jail because it was just a black kid
walking in the street near near a crime
scene and if we are doing documentaries
that because we do believe that as
storyteller
we we can help dreams come true and just
one thing because I know the time is up
this film was supposed to stay in Europe
and thanks to somebody called Christine
Lagarde came to United States and thanks
to wonderful people HBO like Sheila
Nevins and Nancy Abraham this was
possible for you to see I hope when they
and very close soon on HBO thank you
very very much
now the Oscar for documentary Short
subject there are three contenders they
are artists and orphans a true drama
LeeAnn clapper magnetic Saint Peter Lee
mock and Jessica Sanders
Oh Sarah Kerrigan and Lynn hotel
and the Oscar goes to Bob Sarah
Kernighan and Lynn Appel
this is the second Oscar for Sarah
Kernighan and the first four then upheld
ba refers to the subject of the film
escape off the San Francisco violinist
who performs a one
mythical language we thank the Academy
for their wonderful tribute and for
supporting this category still we thank
security for letting Thoth play on the
red carpet I am so grateful to everyone
who helped you make this film and to HBO
which is our new home and a big kiss to
for their support to James and Phoebe
Lapine Jack and Adlai Carnac and then
Romeo Seeley I made this film to call
attention to a man who in a world where
people are waiting so much war this man
takes to the street and wages love
nearly every day of his life and so I
hope that he will think of this as all
that love coming right back at him
thank you
you